what's going on reject nation so if you
guys didn't see it we've just put up a
uh reaction and review right out of the
theater for a quiet place part
two and in that video i mentioned how
there was a q a held right after the
screening
moderated by jj abrams and it was
interviewing john krasinski
and during this live q a uh there were
some social media questions read aloud
and the real rejects were the first ones
read a lot i was like oh whoa that was
surprising
and then our buddy aaron alexander you
might have seen in our invincible uh
reactions in shanxi
he asked a question there and uh just
for
just for some giggles i threw in late to
the party friend of the real rejects
i threw in their question because i
think you guys would get a real hoot out
of that
real kick out of that one so yeah the
whole q a was like 30 plus minutes or
something like that but
i just wanted to share these three with
you all thank you very much enjoy
[Applause]
uh in an actual theater and by the way
uh let's just real quick
here for theaters
it feels so good to walk into a giant
space uh smoking popcorn kind of have an
audience here i know it's not
full capacity but uh it's so beautiful
to to see all of you and to be back
in a theater i'd like to introduce
someone who uh you're really excited
about seeing
ladies and gentlemen the director of a
movie called the white place too mr talk
with history everybody
i can't even joke about that my mom will
disown me
ladies and gentlemen j.j abrams
that's it that's all we wanted to say
thank you so much
i'd like to uh ask you some questions i
have a few questions here and then we'll
take some questions from anyone who has
a question is it bad that i'm nervous
that you're nervous yeah you're the
movie's done oh god that's perfect
um i think that you have made uh
like a masterwork here like what is such
a brilliant
word um you got some questions i should
mind if i
ask you some questions from you you can
answer questions for you i would like to
answer these already that'd be so
disappointing um
what the hell okay the real rejects
ask why was there any pressure to go
bigger in the sequel and so much of the
first one is about keeping it contained
and subtle
not done how did you handle raising the
stakes without
dot dot raising the volume question mark
ooh very nicely worded question
um this sequel is much bigger and much
scarier but
not by my intention as far as i did not
set out to make a bigger or scarier or
any of those things what i did was all i
kept thinking was how do you organically
continue this story
because i know that the secret sauce is
in these characters and in this family
and if you love these people you are
going to be so terrified to see anything
happen to them
whether it's stepping on a nail or um or
whatever it is
it was about these characters and so
once you take away the safety of that
ecosystem the intimacy of that family
that strength that they had
and they have to leave you quite
literally get to the end of the path and
then
every single step they take from there
on out might be their last so
once we got to that part in the movie it
immediately got bigger organically
because you're just more worried for
this
family and then they have to go to new
places and they're going to uncharted
places and places where people have
plans for them and things like that and
so it just started to get bigger
organically and that's when i
just listened to the story i just knew
that if we could make every set
piece that was big big because you can
logically see it that way then we can go
there
so good again i i i'm very jealous of
everyone here because i got to see it in
the theater i was watching it at home
and
went insane over it and i just kept
thinking this is the kind of movie
you really want to see in a theater you
know there's a showing in about 25
but but full of strangers and screaming
together again i mean
it is the thing that i so deeply miss
about this this last you know year and a
bit uh let's take some questions from
this spectacular group of human beings
who are in this theater right now
yes right here oh thanks jj
you obviously know each other
[Laughter]
as someone who's aspiring to make films
myself one day
i have a dream project i want to make
where i'd like to star in it it takes
place over the course of
a year what is the process like of
starring and directing
yourself in a movie this person wants to
star in and direct a movie what is the
process john persisted
call bad robot and
um i i have a weird thing because i
started as an actor first and so
i take great comfort in writing and
directing which
as i'm saying it now sounds very
pretentious the reason why
is when you're in the movie you're
directing you're with the actors and so
it almost feels more like a play
and so without sounding too heady when
certain
actors like everyone in this movie it
starts doing what they're doing you can
actually feel it's almost like
something's rising off the floor and
it's kind of conjuring itself
and the last thing you want to do is go
cut and then it all falls to the ground
and you come out and you go can you just
tilt your head a little more that way
that's great for actors they love that
so being in the scene with them allows
me to
give a note very quietly and so for
instance when i was working with my wife
i'd give her a tiny note and she'd do it
right there in the moment and so the
magic was always around us and so it
almost felt more like we were doing
theater
and that we couldn't cut and so you keep
going and it feels really really
um special when you do that and then the
other thing to be really honest is
logistics as he knows is
for instance in the first movie when i
go up to the silo and lighting the fires
we had i think seven and a half minutes
to shoot that shot before the sun went
down
and in that seven and a half minutes
just looking for an actor i'd lose it so
as soon as as soon as they were like you
have seven and a half minutes i just
went
and start crawling up the silo and i
already knew the note i wanted i knew
which camera we were using and so i got
up there and was able to shoot it in
seven and a half minutes but
it would be hard to to sort of grab an
actor
give them a note and all that while the
sun's going down
good luck with your movie but late to
the party asks
uh besides kevin for obvious reasons who
from dunder mifflin
would survive the longest in your silent
well post-population both have to answer
this because i don't know i'm sure you
know jj abrams directed the office
no please no all of all of them uh
it's a good question for you i mean
listen it's an easy answer but
uh everyone thinks i'm gonna say dwight
and that's not true
definitely creed creed would find his
way into a
rabbit hole and just wave it out and eat
mung beans and have a good time
where did you get the socks they're
excellent oh
the the socks are on full display i know
my long legs are just sort of
just i'm jerry this is a fan well it's a
lariat
my stylist who basically took me out of
the world of sweatpants for a very long
time and she's got
sick sucking well done i will say this
um it is incredibly hard to do what you
made look effortless
uh and you've made a movie that uh yes
to horror movie
but it shouldn't be categorized like
that i think it is a movie about family
and uh about being tested and
like the great you know films that we
all love that
inspired you the film by spielberg and
hitchcock and
and many others uh you've taken
something and and
you've you've done kind of the
impossible especially given that
it is a sequel which i would argue is a
better film even in the first which i
loved
i think you've made a movie that just
touches the sort of primal
place in us and for audiences who are
used to so much
um and has seen so much you've really
done something that is
remarkable and you made it look so easy
so i commend you and congratulate you
and uh to anyone who is watching has not
seen it
quiet plays part two ladies and
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
gentlemen
have a good night everybody